progressives need to know the right way
to fight Donald Trump and as a sort of
reminder I said right away after the
election of President Donald we need to
fight him on policy where it makes sense
but we need to push him to do the things
where he aligns with progressives the
areas were Trump aligned with Bernie
Sanders and steak two issues
specifically and there's a fascinating
article you have to read this article in
the new york times by luigi zingales
which agrees with a lot of what I've
been saying why do we care what luigi
zingales rights in the New York Times
well he's from Italy and he saw
firsthand how Silvio Berlusconi came to
power with a very similar rhetoric to
that of Donald Trump's and it ended up
we saw with Silvio Berlusconi up one of
the most corrupt and long-lasting
Italian leaders in part because of the
in competence of the opposition this I
cannot possibly overstate the importance
of this in Italy much of the opposition
to Silvio Berlusconi was personality
based and this is sort of equivalent to
the focus on Trump making fun of
disabled reporters and women calling
this group or that group rapists or
criminals that is absolutely worthy of
critique okay but it failed to deny
Donald Trump the presidency so
progressives need to get today that it
isn't likely to deny him reelection nor
is it likely to deny him the ability to
do stuff during his presidency luigi
zingales sites these anti-trump protests
that are happening after the election
and he explains that Trump won I mean we
think we're still in the middle of some
recounts that Trump won in spite of the
personality and and sort of I don't know
what you would call them off color type
arguments against Donald Trump and that
protesting his actions before he
actually takes actions as illegitimate
if indeed Trump did win is sort of going
in the direct
the strategy that failed to oust silvio
berlusconi in italy and as as examples
of the right way to fight Berlusconi
Trump like leaders zing galas sites in
this article two people Romano Prodi and
Matteo Renzi these are two men who were
able to defeat Silvio Berlusconi in
Italy and they did to two things that
are really important number one they
pretended that Berlusconi was sort of a
regular opponent and it's really hard to
treat Donald Trump as if he's a regular
elected official because he's so
buffoonish ly uninformed and incompetent
on just about every issue and number two
Renzi and Prada in Italy focused on
issues and not character and then
zingales goes on to agree with me almost
word-for-word focus on number one where
does agreement exists with Donald Trump
as progressives infrastructure deals
even though the way Trump is structuring
his infrastructure deals it's basically
corrupt crony capitalism but okay
infrastructure is something generally
that it's more the left that agrees with
Trump than the right encouraged Trump to
do what he said in terms of reinstating
some kind some new version of
glass-steagall but then disagree
vehemently aggressively on all the other
policies that make no sense and there's
another advantage to this strategy in
terms of it having been shown to be
effective in Italy against a trump like
Berlusconi it can help drive a wedge
between Trump and establishment
Republicans seeing Trump work with
Democrats on issues like more
regulations for separating the
commercial and investment sides of
banking seeing Trump work with Democrats
on things like government spending via
infrastructure this is going to be
unpalatable to many Republicans some are
just going to fall in line with whatever
Donald Trump does because of the cult of
personality but it can also serve to
drive a wedge between the Republicans
who really didn't like Hillary but are
still traditional Republicans in that
they don't want government spending and
they don't want banking
regulation and they want neoconservative
intervention in the Middle East this
conserve I would call it a two sided
purpose but it's really more like three
or four we need to be very aware of what
luigi zingales wrote in The New York
Times we're linking to the article in
the description to the YouTube video for
this story and it really is overlapping
with a lot of what I've been saying and
this is why it makes it all the more
important uh to actually have
progressives coordinated and engage the
way I'm proposing we do and we're going
to be having a fundraiser starting
sooner than later to raise money for
that and a lot of other things that
progresses really need to get together
let's take a break any thoughts on this
tweet me i'm on twitter at d pakman